café c'est ok les julots des biscuits
secs c'est bon très bien alors que la
ville s'éveille la marotte de l'a6 samu
social va à la rencontre de ceux qui ont
dormi dans la rue autour d'un café les
agents de médiation tente de nouer le
dialogue et la proposition on n'a rien
d'autre à changer déjà tu peux dormir
qui peuvent déjeuner comme cyril steve a
passé une grande partie de sa vie dans
la rue et malgré la violence qui sévit
ils préfèrent dormir dehors vous
aimeriez sortir de la rue non pas encore
pas encore pas encore malgré les
violences si c'est un beau problème
c'est pas mon problème ce qui tue ceux
qui disent qu'ils parlent de combler
justement je me suis qu'un consommateur
et c'est tout ne jamais contraindre mais
toujours proposé c'est ce qui permet aux
agents de médiation de créer une
relation de confiance
ce sont des parents bout on va pas
négliger nos parents mais on pense à eux
aussi parce qu'ils font beaucoup pour
nous quand il sera prêt steve pourrait
être prise en charge par la cie samu
social
une démarche qui peut s'étaler sur
plusieurs années d'où l'importance pour
les travailleurs sociaux d'être présent
sur le terrain l'assise dispose de deux
dispositifs liés au social éducatif aux
sanitaires à la psychiatrie avec
l'équipe de lémery
mais aussi de tout le réseau c'est ce
dispositif nos maraudes certes à amener
la personne vers la réhabilitation
psychosociale quasiment 70 lits
accueille des personnes en grande
précarité
il y a les places d'urgence et celle de
stabilisation emmanuel à 22 ans il a
connu les squats et les galères depuis
un mois il peut enfin souffler prenez
une bonne vie sociale me remettre sur de
bonnes bases
j'avais pas de logement donc maintenant
je peux je peux je suis nourrie logis
je m'unis votre chemin
prendre des douches avant une bonne
hygiène de vie ou le samu social a
dénombré environ 200 sdf sur le
territoire en 2018 grâce à la maraude
la structure a réalisé plus de 7000
rencontre dans les rues de lille un
maillon essentiel dans la prise en
charge des personnes en difficulté